على التليفون انا وينك عندنا مشوار كذا
ادرى اذا اوكي
[موسيقى]
ولا نساء فقط كنت اشتغل بماما المواد
الغذائيه لما وصلت لمرحله انه انا الشغل
اللي كنت اشتغل فيه كان اشتغل مثلا نهار
يعطل الجمعه نشتغل جمعه معطل ان شاء الله
من وراء وضع البلد يعني لما انصرت الازمه
وشغل ما في اضطريت تقول بالشغل
هو هذا الشغل معروف انه للشباب مضبوط بس
انا كان عندي هوايه ان السوق المتوفي
والعيل اللي عندنا خلافه اولاد خالاتي
اللي بيطلب مني مثلا خلينا على محل افلام
روحي جيبي لي هيك ومن وراء هذه الشغله
شجعت وصرت اعملها اول شيء يعني جبت متوسط
بدون ما اهلي يعرفوا وبعدين شوي شوي
تاكرموا على الموضوع قالوا لي كثير هاي
للصبيان ومش للبنات
بس انا كانت عندي اياها لانه في ناس كثير
ما بتحب انا شو بتشتغل
ما بيقلب وجهي مثلا
[موسيقى]